هاتفي galaxy s22 و s22 plus هما هنا
عدسة جديدة بعرض 50 ميجابكسل
توفر دقة محسّنة
ويسمح مستشعرها الأكبر بدخول المزيد من الضوء
بحيث يبدو الجميع بمظهر رائع ليلاً أو نهارًا ،
وهناك أيضًا عدسة تليفونية جديدة بدقة 10 ميجابكسل
مع تقريب بصري ثلاث مرات مما
يعني أنه يمكنك  ضوء السفر ولا يزال
يلتقط صورًا رائعة
حتى عندما أكون في حالة حركة ، يكون الفيديو الخاص بي
مستقرًا
، وذلك بسبب زاوية تصحيح أوسع بمقدار 58
لتثبيت الصورة البصرية
وتثبيت الصورة الرقمية للفيديو الذي
يحلل أربعة أضعاف بيانات الحركة أكثر
من ذي قبل
مع المجرة s 22  قام
مهندسونا ومطورونا بتركيب
هذا الدبوس ببراعة في الجهاز
نفسه مع الحفاظ على الأداء العالي
بما في ذلك أقوى
إطار من الألومنيوم المدرع حتى الآن
و corning gorilla glass victus plus
gorilla glass victus plus الموجود في كل من الجزء
الأمامي والخلفي للجهاز وهو
حاليًا حصري لـ  سلسلة galaxy s22
مع galaxy s22 Ultra نقدم
لك شاشة ديناميكية غامرة مقاس 6.8 بوصة بتقنية
amoled 2x  وضع مع معدلات التحديث التكيفية
، قام المصممون والمهندسون لدينا بدمج
البرامج القوية مع
الأجهزة القوية لتقديم كاميرا رباعية العدسة
مع إعداد تقريب مساحة 100 مرة ، بالإضافة إلى
معيار صناعي آخر
يوسع نوع المحتوى الذي يمكنك
إنشاؤه ويجلب القوة الإبداعية بين
يديك بإحكام
لتقديم  iphone 13
pro في الوضع الاحترافي ، يمكنك
ضبط سرعة الغالق
يدويًا التركيز اليدوي ISO وتوازن اللون الأبيض
، القوة الأساسية لأي هاتف ذكي موجودة في
معالجها ، يأتي galaxy s 22
Ultra
بمعالج قوي رباعي النانومتر ، وستتوفر أسرع شريحة لدينا على الإطلاق galaxy
s22  بالنسبة لـ 799
و s22 plus ستكون متاحة لـ 999
galaxy s22 Ultra وستتوفر
للطلب المسبق بدءًا من اليوم بسعر 1199 دولارًا
[موسيقى]
لك